[Sylvia Brodach] I come from a family of six children.
[Frances Goldstein] And I was the oldest.
[Sylvia] Yeah. In between us, there was our
brother, Chaim.
And after me, my mother had twins.
But, ah, one of them died. Her name was
Freda.
Then is Judith.
And a little brother, Yankov.
[Frances] And we lived a very happy life.
My father was a businessman.
And we were educated in Czechit [Czech] and in Yiddish.
We had the yeshiva in the town that we supported.
[Sylvia] We never experienced any anti-Semitism
under the Czech government.
We associated.
My friends were Czech, you know?
So we had a very happy home life.
[Frances] The Hungarian army came in.
[Sylvia] And they occupied—
[Frances] And they occupied the Karpath [Carpathians].
[Sylvia] They took our business away.
[Frances] They just plain-blind came in and
then took over.  [Sylvia] They occupied it.
[Frances] And they told you, "get out," and that was it.
[Sylvia] There was, like, rumbling.
Rows of tanks were coming through the town.
And they parked those tanks in the center
and we heard those noises during the night.
And in the morning, there was a knock on our door.
And there were two SS standing.
And he said, "Let's go."
[Sylvia] Towards the end, they started to
liquidate the ghetto.
They started to ship people out.
[Frances] We went like they ship animals.
You know, those open trains?
[Sylvia] They never opened up the cars.
It never stopped.
It just constantly was going.
And we were suffocated, practically, there.
And because there were so many people
crammed into a small place,
there was no water. People were fainting.
Elderly people were dying.
And finally, after three days of traveling,
the train suddenly stopped.
They suddenly opened up the doors.
[Frances] And I heard they say that men here, this goes here.
The people start panicking. [Sylvia] Everybody started coming—
[Frances] They didn't know, and they was going with
those rubber sticks, you know, here, there.
And we were very scared. And we didn't know nothing.
I remember my father,
he was grabbing my brother, you know.
And my mother, the four, the five—
the five kids. My mother and me, my sister,
we were holding together.
[SIGHS]
And as we come down,
they were... The SS pushed my father here.
[Sylvia] They announced it.
[Frances] And we go here.
And my mother was going with me, with my sister.
And they was 8, 10, 11.
They pushed her here.
And I remember, my, my mother—
the kids start crying, “Mommy, mommy,” you know?
And my mother pulled herself away from me.
And she says, [speaks in Yiddish]
“You should take care of your sister,
like if you were a—” [Sylvia] I know, Frances.
[Sylvia] The minute we stepped off the freight train,
we were separated, right there and then.
My father and my older brother went on one side.
My sister, she was a tall girl.
So they made her go to one side.
And I went with my mother
and with the, uh, younger children.
And my mother looked around.
And she says, “Well, where is, uh, your sister?”
I said, “They made her go over there.”
So she tells me,
"You run after her,
because she only has one dress on her."
And they pushed her in one side.
And I was running
from one place to another and I don't know how.
Because in Auschwitz, you just did not
run from one place to another.
But somehow, I caught up with her.
And, uh, I found her.
And we were marching, you know?
They took us into a section, where
all the women arrivals came in.
And that was a big, long barrack. And you stayed there.
We were in Auschwitz for three days, in barracks.
And outside, all that going on, there was
a big band playing music constantly, day and night.
There was smoke, heavy smoke.
There were babies screaming.
You were looking where it's come from,
but you couldn't see where it's come from.
[Frances] Everybody was screaming and crying and running,
and they says, you know, "Don't cry,
you'll be after they go shower in there,
you'll meet them in afternoon to meet again."
[Frances] And since then I have never seen
[Sylvia] That was the last time we saw
[Sylvia] my father, my brother, my grandmother,
my mother, and the—and the four youngers.
[Frances] my mother, my father,
[Frances] and my sisters and my brother.
That was the last time I seen them.
[Sylvia] I had never heard anything about
my rest of the family.
Until one day, I was sitting by the window.
I was mending the socks.
And this friend of mine walks into the room,
and he said to me, “Sylvia,
what are you going to give me?
I have a surprise for you."
And I picked up my head,
and I saw my sister standing in the yard,
you know, in the courtyard.
So first, I thought I was seeing things.
And then she gave a yell,
and I ran out in the courtyard.
And we both fainted right there on the spot.